[Applause]
see a sports coverage to the NFL brings
us to Gillette Stadium in Foxborough
mass a moment ago the defending Super
Bowl champs introduced to this fired up
crowd here in Foxborough as the Patriots
get set to do battle with mat Lyon and
the defending NFC champions the Atlanta
Falcons hey everyone its Peter Brown
standing in for Alex Newhouse for his
review of Madden 18
although Madden releases feature a
little more than mechanical tweaks and
roster updates Madden NFL 18 is
highlighted by one of the most
significant additions in the series
history a full story mode and this is on
top of a much more graphically capable
engine as well as a result Madden 18 is
a distinct improvement over the last
several entries in the series
[Applause]
touchdown
[Applause]
Madden games rarely tackled a personal
side of football choosing instead to
present it as a chess like competition
you are the coach and master the players
are your instruments to score of course
that's not how football is treated in
the real world so to see that change in
Madden is intriguing in theory and
gratifying in practice the longshot
story mode actually references the deep
emotional investment people have in the
sport and how high the stakes are for
them for example main character Devon
Wade the star football player from his
small Texas town quits his college team
after a family tragedy you navigate
through Wade's attempt to return to
football traveling to the NFL Combine in
order to impress Scouts longshot is
surprisingly deep it's a fully fledged
telltale style adventure game with
multiple endings broken up by short
moments of actually playing football it
presents you with decisions that affect
both the people around you and the
scouts perception of you as with
telltale games there's an illusion of
greater choice that isn't necessarily
there but longshots succeeds because it
makes minor choices feel important I'll
pass I'm a football player not an actor
Oh football player huh what team do you
play for the mode is at its best when
his characters speak honestly about
their love for the sport nailing the
sense that football offers something
bigger a connection to a community and a
way to achieve greatness it has issues
with over-the-top spectacle but on the
whole this first attempt at a story mode
from Madden creates an excellent
foundation for the series further once
you finish long shot you can dive into
madden ultimate team to play through
Devon Wade's most memorable football
scenarios has been impressive so far in
relief of caleb young bringing the
bullfrogs back from a huge deficit
freak around and win this game madden
ultimate team is undoubtedly Madden's
deepest mode which has received a suite
of updates to make it even more
appealing to returning players you'll
get player cards representing Devon Wade
Colt Cruz and other characters from long
shot and forming a long shot focused
mutt team lets you participate in around
30 challenges although these challenges
are generally not much more than normal
Madden scenarios with longshot player
models they're still entertaining enough
to be worth playing on the field Madden
a team looks beautiful the game is the
first in the series to use EA's
frostbite engine and as a result certain
moments look nearly photorealistic
stadiums feature minor details while
player models show everything from arm
tattoos to jersey wrinkles Stadium
lighting is a particular high point for
example afternoon sunlight partially
blocked by the stadium edges filters
down on the parts of the field and
realistically illuminates players as
they run into the light the transition
to frostbite isn't perfect though
outside of stadium's environments
generally look bland and featureless
especially during segments of long shot
additionally with more human-like player
movements come some bizarre graphical
bugs such as a player's leg clipping
through his tacklers chest where two
players getting hung up on each other as
they try to stand up as with past Madden
games EA is trying to make sure that the
game reflects real NFL events as much as
possible which means weekly roster and
player stat updates this year EA has
also added the play now live mode which
allows you to jump quickly into any of
this week's matchups and both teams will
reflect the actual lineups set to play
EA Tiburon has also introduced the
ability to turn play now live games into
a franchise letting you jump into a full
season immediately after completing the
game even though franchise mode hasn't
received many updates from last year's
version these new starting points make
it a whole lot easier and more enticing
to play through an entire season
[Applause]
sixteen touchdown
[Applause]
overall Madden 18 marks an unusually
large shake-up in a series that due to
its annualized releases rarely features
more than small iterative changes the
Frostbite engine allows the game to
achieve new levels of realism in its
visuals an EA has put a lot of effort
into constantly evolving the game to
keep it in line with real world events
but it is the longshots story mode that
defines Madden 18 some of longshot is
unnecessary spectacle but it's lasting
value comes from the humanity that it
brings to the game these moments of
vulnerability and sincerity between
Devon Wade and Colt Cruz during the
story are worthy of celebration and give
the overall game a weight that madden
hasn't had before and if that's not
enough to entice you it's also simply a
terrific football game
[Music]
you
[Music]